depuis mercredi les berruyers peuvent
choisir entre les terrasses et le musée
pour clément s'est exposé au muséum
je suis aussi un puriste des terrasses
fait de boire un coup avec mes amis mais
ça change
c'était l'occasion de venir on
connaissait pas donc ça change c'est une
bonne chose
là ça fait déjà peut-être dix minutes un
quart d'heure qu'on est sur l'expo dont
quoi va être très très belle expo comme
vivre les 100 meilleures photos de
nature pour 2020 sont présentés ici à
bourges et c'est un enchantement
chaque année depuis 32 ans pour moi en
tout cas encore plus intéressant je me
nourris de ces de ces clichés que je me
sens incapable de faire c'est pas c'est
pas du tout quelque chose que je peux
faire donc c'est formidable c'est comme
voir des galeries d'artistes avec de la
peinture
on se dit voilà c'est magnifique
certains courent le monde pour relever
des pièges photographiques d'autres
planque à l'affût par des -40
c'est hyper intéressant de découvrir en
fait de nouvelles choses et
des choses qu'on auxquelles on n'a pas
forcément accès tout le temps ça
m'intéresse mais j'ai pas l'occasion de
voir autant de photos et de si jolies
photos c'est une quête faite d'humilité
d'exigence immense les trouve très très
belle est vraiment des des gens qui
s'investissent autant parce que je pense
qu'il faut tellement de temps pour faire
des belles photos oui je trouve que
c'est très très intéressant et c'est une
très belle expo une poésie d'image à la
fois puissante et fragile où la violence
des hommes peu révulsés à voir sans
modération jusqu'au 30 juin